yo creo que más allá de la plata que se
podría gastar y sabemos los medios que
tiene a su disposición en eeuu son las
11 oportunidades que puede nombrar en
las cuales el conjunto del congreso se
levantó para aplaudir si iniciando con
casi un minuto de aplausos a la
embajadora ucraniana ante las naciones
unidas así las cosas el presidente de
eeuu está demostrando un liderazgo
liderazgo nacional estadounidense pero
también internacional con una medida que
me parece más relevante aún que el gasto
de mil millones de dólares y es el
desbloqueo de en total 10 por ciento de
las reservas de petróleo de la
disposición de eeuu 50 millones de
barriles al inicio de la semana y 30
millones más que se acaban de anunciar
esto con el fin de estabilizar el precio
internacional del petróleo lo que va
mucho más allá de un gasto destinado a
ucrania sino que muestra a su voluntad
de apoyar a toda costa no solamente a
los estadounidenses para el precio de su
gasolina sino el conjunto de sus aliados
en el esfuerzo que están
cumpliendo para apoyar a ucrania